Дякую шановна люлія Михайлівна Шановні
колеги справді У нас дуже стислий
регламент лі Михайлівна наголосила
регламент для доповіді 12 хвилин За цей
час потрібно дати цілісну картину
здобутків університету не розмінюючись
на деталі дати основне дати ті наукові
результати які справді
можна пропагувати для всього суспільства
як приклад того що ви не Деревно
витрачає гроші на науку водночас прошу
зупинитися на головних тенденціях
розвитку наукових досліджень
на динаміці людей які беруть участь в
цих дослідженнях на динаміці
фінансування в тому числі і формування
спеціального фонду на тому Які у вас є
успіхи в інноваційній і публікаційній
діяльності зупинитися Як ви
використовуєте сьогодні можливості
міжнародного співробітництва ще раз
підкреслюю 12 хвилин на доповідь я буду
жорстко стежити з регламентом 3 хвилини
годому запитання відповіді короткі це
можуть ставити всі від вітра
Олександрович викитаєте головою але
однак треба втриматися Харківський
національний університет імені Каразіна
е Віктор Олександрович каркович
проректор наукової роботи прошу
же сьогодні університет - це 20
факультетів більше 16 000 студентків
птьте пть обєк національння і 25
державних премій України в галузі науки
і техніки отримані заро
безсві у 2016 році в університеті від
пам'ятники трьом варіатам мії діяльності
яки по університет університет шановує
пам'ят своїх суслі і долючеників шановує
пам'яті своїх героїв ворів АТО і
приділяють велику увагу вихованню
молодого покоління як науковців так і
патріотів своєї батьківщини в
університеті 27 січня цього року
відкрито меморіальну дошку студентам та
вихованського університету заренивої
рої це виховансько у нас історичного
медичного факультетуі університету і
указа президента України вихованця
історічного факультету рослава мису
нагороджена орденом Богдана хницького
третього ступеня 18 а 22 лютого 16 року
і президента України орденом замужність
третього ступеня загорожена студента
четвертого курсу іологічного факультету
Віта
о наступний
слайд основа діяльності університету -
Це безумовно науково-педагогічний кадр
чисельність штатних працівників
університеті складає майже 1600 осіб з
них докторів наук 240 800 канди
ДАІ і закінчилось в нас небагато всього
19 робіт продовжується виконуватись
роботи за
64 ро обсяг фінансування наукового
дослідноіти і загального фонду складає
понад 33 млн грн а обсяг надходження
спеціального фонду складає більше
16 млн
г ну Це
обсягифінансування та кількість
науководослідних робіт які виконувались
встніро вони цідажеці назні і все
зрозуміло що
дуже
стисло цьому році у міжнародній
науково-метричній базі даних скопус
університет вперше надрукував
опублікував більш с
робіт
за показниками міжнародної бази даних
скопус університет займає наступні
наступний
рег за рішенням видавництва томсонрейрс
Міністерство освіти і науки України над
України університет став лауреати у
категорії за інтегрованість у світову
науку якуєсти найбільшою кількістю
публікацій зроблених по міжнародній
Науковій
співпраці кількість
монографій
десь порядка 130 да
далі підготовка науковиканя в
університеті функціонує 25
спеціалізованих рад із захисту
докторських і кандидатських дисертацій
а працівниками університету захищено
90дисертаційни по погарокам оцей слайд
каже що робилиж ро за і таі
результати дозволили університету
зайняти провідні позиції у міжнародних
рейтингкорвець ренківсь
382 позицію Ну як кажуть бажано краще
але є то ще є
дуже стисло стосовно вашлиних
результатів за закінчено в 16му році їх
всього в нас
шість я не дума озвучувати мабуть назву
робіт вони де не сда я тільки акцентую
увагу за якими проблемами вони
виконуються так От ця робота пов'язана з
розвитком проблеми виготовлення Нано та
мікророзмірних композитних матеріалів в
роботі вперше розвинуто теорію та
розраховано швидкість росту і Су
одношарових полицевих нанотрубкав у плаі
і вперше розроблена теорія формування
нагних структур у плазмі за цією роботою
у міжнародній наукометричній базі даних
скопус надруковано 40 хк наступка наступ
е ця робота спрямована на сворення
новітніх елементів пам'яті інформаційних
систем на основі шаруватої
магнітноїструктури за такими структурами
майбутнє атитехнологі по суті в роботі
досліджуні питання щодо зачасного
моделювання нелінійного електричного ко
кола та переносу спільного електрона у
форматі нелінійній Магні нату 17
публікацій
ус наступне е ця робота спрямована на на
розв'язок Ну взагаліто проблеми
світового рівня Це створення
географічно-телевізійної системи
Сполучені Штати Америки витратили на ці
дослідження понад 10 млрд доларів а
Японія понад 7 млрд доларів Ну щось нема
такої системи Ну во всяком случаї ми
надє і Ми надіємось що щось було Також
там відзначено що вперше теоретично
обґрунтованабудована теорія синтезування
телевізійних програм і створено макет
лабораторї галорифічної телевізійної
системи надіємось що далі
що Дуже
хотілось
[музика]
фінансування
наступне ну сьогодні є нагальна як
кажуть нагальна проблема часу це
забезпечення розвитку сучасних
багатофункціональних
радіоелектронних радіолокаційних систем
у тому числі спеціально
призначення основою цих систем є
створення новідних випромінюючих
структур з керуючими елементами так От
ця робота
і спрямована на те щоб створити такі
нові структури створити необ ні
радіотаціонні системи і за цією роботою
24 публікації у
скопці
наступна науковий напрямок цієї роботи -
це формування плівкових структурних
елементів на навітруніки в роботі
розроблено метод реєстрації фазового
стану клівкової системи під час її
виготовлення важливі результати за
закінченими у 16-му році таких робіт у
нас всього
13 ця робота спрямована на створення
радіотехнічних систем спеціального
призначення в роботі розроблено
чотири
антесистеми одна із них
широкосмогалантина для мобільного
радіоколенатора вона є основою для
створення портативного
рагулінгатора і
яки є основним елементом для створення
си системи електронної протидії і
забезпечення ефективного зв'язку
нестандартних умов
ну антена широкослугова для засобів
радіозв'язку з мобільними об'єктами такі
характеристики антени дають змогу
застосовувати її
зараз Випробування проходять зараз на
танках бойових машинах піхоти
ротранспортирах автомобілях і так даліє
і впроваджується у держа підприємстві
прото
наступне також
в рамках цієї роботи створення Космо для
захобів мобільного зв'язку призначено
для використання в трансляторах
випромінюючих систем придушення сигналів
на об'єктах загального користування та
засобів безпеки проня дії то есть її
можу по-русски потут можно включить и
мобль на связи и
локомотивна малаборитина гектометрового
діапазону Вона
зараз впроваджується на дежаного
підприємстві ом
для со
Локомотив
звязку далі потреба часу - це проблема
науково-технічного та
матергаль науковотехнічні та труднощі
контролю помітності зразків воєнної
техніки то ти роботи зано для стування
При проектуванні зразків військової
техніки На КБ іні
борозова
наступ Ну були роботи у нас
які які досліджували як
треба відходи ядерного палива зберігати
так щоб вони не не шкодить нікому А
тепер робота присвячена тому щоби
розроблена методика багатояросного
завантаження в контейнері боче ну з
відходами наденого палива і що дозволяє
забезпечити умови радіаційної безпеки її
зберігання нудуже сстисла наступна
робота - це захист довкілля відг впливу
начиста слічних НТА безпечного
використання відвальних доменних шлаків
про жується там
написано робота спрямована на
впровадження технології кренного
навчання вищій школі розробленя
концептуальні засади та Конні технології
впровадженняня наступне
це робота спрямована на створення
новітніх технології профілактики та
лікування захворювань ізкти
ізклитинво для молозила порів виділені
компоненти які забезпечують системний
захист організму токсинів різної роди
вони рекомендовані яної фармацевтич рук
впроваджуються у клінічних засгах
наступне
це дуже
така глобальна робота вона спрямована на
створення новітніх нанокомпозиційних
матеріалів
поліфункціонального
призначення розроблено основамих
матеріалів із заданими параметрами для
створеня елементів пам'яті нолітніх
зразків електробра надміцних матеріалів
розробки технологтичних процесів і
алгоритмів детелізації
і результати цієї Боди впроваджені для
розробки лопаток газових турбін також в
рамках цієї роботи один із напрямків її
- це створення нові діх
наноструктурованих матеріалів для
мікронаноелектроніки високоточних
пристроїв вимірюванняв і захисту
інформації виконується також пограмка
гранту горизонт 2228 публікацій у скоп
фух напрямок цієї роботи - Це розробка
приладів для висоточного виміру
елементного складу речовин зроблено
створено джерело яке на три податки
більше е дає змогу має високу відносні
сусильності викамінювання від
діючих
наступне
у попередні роки ми представляли
роботу
коли розв'язували
задачу з нанесення у
у укрипляющ зміцнюва зміснюваня зміснюва
поі а це робота де і ЗМІ юємо і
покриваємо керамікою
і маємо успішне поєднання механічних
властивостей металів з хінічною
стійкістю керамічних матеріалів хінічне
випробовування проходить Ну і дуже
стисло зароботали які перехідні таких 64
роботи
ни дуже стисно в останні
роки на сьогодні ну на сьогодні значи
фінансування наукового досліджень які
мають важливе значення для
бороноздатності країни та вирішення
задач впк сьогодні от десь біля 9 млн ми
виконуємо таких робт із них що показово
це більше 5 млн за фундаментальними
роботами університет плідно співпрацює з
багатьма підприємствами державного
концепту укрборомпро
справедливо нде нди України е входить до
складу кластеру мехатро 50
високотехнологічних підприємств України
та ВНЗ і
тому
слідуч тому продовжується дослідження у
напрямку радіофізичної
енроскопії радіометрії це технології
інпульсної
локації вони пов'язані з розробкою дик
розрахунку та вимірювання в ближній зоні
характеристик
радіолокаційних помітності та створення
багатоспектального комплексу для
вимірювання кофціленто в от там
так також продовжується дослідження
зокрема для вирішування проблеми
виявлення нерозігланих боєприпасів та
міно рослинності та поверхневому шарі
від військових іноді чути тако що Та що
ж ви її вирішуєте вирішуєте Ну о
там с я по-российски с правой стороны
Вот там обозначены все проблемы которые
нужно решить для того чтобы их создать а
проблемы если на них посмотриш так это
каждая из перечесленных своя
проблема дуже потрібна і своєчас робота
розробки та створеня систем та засобів
захисту інформації заводозахищених
радіоканалів передачі даних систем
запобігання несанкціновим дія в складних
автомазованих системах управління і
особливо систем пропередження і захисту
від несакціонованого застосування
високоточної
зброї у 15-му році ми доповідали тут
роботу Ні Ніні Ні
таке
повинен бути ще слайд з астрономі
астрономії А во
ее робота де вперше в світі розроблений
застосований паларизаційний метод
баазових відносинь оцінки порушення
грунту коли на місяць але дві хвилини ще
о коли на місяць прилинився апарат був
китайський тутбола апарат Пола 16 І от
від газових турбін
этих апола
нарушку можна пороски нарушился грунт и
этот метод позволяет определить Что и
как этот грунт нарушился так вот сегодня
запропоновано поширити цей метод для
дослідження Земної порх як можна його
застосувати для того щоб якщо там ворог
щось там вирик щось накрив щось спрятав
і визначити що воно там
зробно
Ну також продовжується дослідження щодо
створення новітніх лікарств лікарських
препаратів на основи нарозмірних часток
середра розробки сучасних засобів
меничної діагностики та
терапії
і як я казав
руп
64 про все не скажше міжнародне
співробітницво університет в 16-му році
за міжнародними програмами і
партнерськими угодами виконував 14 робіт
з них два в горизон ті
деякі приклади участі в міжнародних
грантах
дуже так стисло їх
про показати мож 46й град
46 слайд з офісом США була работа на о
19,93 млн грн і наступний слайд
Це ось з благодійний грант компанії
Shell був 200 млн грн далі приклади ее
індивідуальних дослідницьких
грантів далі далі далі далі приклади
науково-дослідних робіт науко да
приклади наукови дослі бід інституту
інформаційних технологій більше мільйона
спстема співденни до речі співденним
зараз все більше і більше ми виконуємо
робіт науково-досвідна робота студентів
проводиться
Е бронзовамедальна міжнародна торніня
інних фізиків отримали наші студенти
зрівномедаль міжні олімпіаді з фізики
бро
[музика]
диплом другого ступе на міжнародній
олімпіаді теретичної ді
хальників наукова робота
них вчельних на цьому
слайді Ну і пропозиції
пропозиції вони як кажуть із рухово
рі Дякую за увагу Дякую дуже Вікторе